With a hilarious deleted post-credits
scene, a surprise ending for Camilo,
and an even darker fate for Abuela's husband,
the ending of Encanto was almost very different.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and
in this video I'm revealing the alternate
endings for Encanto you never got to see!
Spoilers ahead of course, so take care.
During the beautiful, melancholy song "Dos
Oruguitas", we get the full backstory of
Abuela and her husband Pedro, how they met, fell
in love, got married, had triplets and then how
he tragically died trying to protect his family
and the townspeople from a group of soldiers.
However, this scene was originally
going to be even more heart-breaking
because in early drafts, Alma and Pedro had to
flee their town before the children were born,
and according to Encanto co-director
Jared Bush, "there was a version where
she had the babies at the river and they
were born the same moment Pedro died."
Now, Pedro's fate was already
pretty dark for a Disney movie,
but I think that Alma giving birth as her husband
died beside her would have been even more bleak.
There is a tiny trace of this idea though
in the final movie in the following line
which Bush has confirmed does imply that Pedro
died on the very day the triplets were born.
When my three babies had just been born, your
Abuelo Pedro and I were forced to flee our home.
Thankfully they decided not to
go with this alternate ending,
meaning Pedro did at least get to say goodbye
to his three children before his death.
Bush also revealed that Chispi the capybara
had a funny, fully-animated post-credits
scene that didn't make it into the movie.
In the deleted scene, Chispi lifts his leg
to relieve himself on the casita, but the
magical house stops the capybara by tipping
a drain full of water on him, giving the
creature a taste of his own medicine.
Bush said the scene was cut because they
preferred to finish the movie "on the emotion
and joy of the family coming back together."
The mischievous casita can also be seen pranking
a capybara in this unused concept art where
it tips the cute creature off a chair.
In another alternate storyline, Mirabel had
a confrontation with her mother Julieta at
the end of the movie rather than with her
grandmother as happened in the final film.
In this version, it was Mirabel's anger with
her mother that led to the Casita's destruction,
as with each angry word she uttered, it was
as if a blow was being struck to the house,
causing it to break apart.
The idea was that Mirabel and Casita
"shared a mental connection", so her rage
would end up wrecking the family home.
In another version of the story, Casita was
destroyed by fire, burning to the ground,
rather than crumbling to pieces.
It would have been especially poignant for
a fire to destroy the magical house given
that it owed its existence to a candle.
In the aftermath of the fire, the windows
and doors survived to give a sense of the
original layout of the house, and a spooky
ghost-like shadow was also going to appear.
This was supposed to feel like there was a ghostly
spirit still in the ruins of the house, a shadow
that haunted it, perhaps that of Abuela's Pedro.
It was meant to feel scary and threatening
although as the camera drew closer,
it would be revealed to actually be
the remaining cracks of the house.
A potentially confusing alternate ending
for Camilo was considered at one time where
according to Jared Bush, after the house fell
and the magic died, Camilo "reverted to his
true self [...] and no one recognized him."
That ending would have meant that the appearance
we saw Camilo use throughout the movie
when he wasn't shapeshifting wasn't
actually his real form, it was just
another character he was pretending to be.
I can see this ending for Camilo could have
been too distracting given the number
of questions it would have raised and,
as Bush explained, it was scrapped because
"the moment had to be about Mirabel".
The casita also took on some creepy, ghost-like
characteristics in this unused concept art where
the house revealed there was something wrong by
having all the paintings and pictures go blank.
The idea here was that Casita was sick
in a way and was experiencing the kind of
memory loss or brain fog that people can get
sometimes when they're sick or suffering.
Another way to represent the magic going
wrong was this scene where the yellow
butterflies would have all gone dark giving
the moment a very spooky and creepy vibe.
And these unused pieces of concept art
show how, in another version of the movie,
Casita could literally float above the
ground, both before it was destroyed and
later again when Mirabel restores it.
A deleted scene released by Disney on the
Encanto Blu-ray appears to follow up on
the confrontation I mentioned earlier
between Mirabel and her mother Julieta.
The cut scene takes place after a devastated
Mirabel has fled the Encanto, filled with
guilt and regret for how she believes
she's to blame for the state of the family,
and Alma decides to go in search of her.
Abuela sets out on her own, promising that
when she returns and Julieta has healed,
they will repair the family stronger than ever.
After Abuela arrives in her former home town,
she discovers a mural dedicated to her beloved
Pedro with the words "To Love At All Is To Love
Entirely" and a painting of him in the river with
his arms held up, which honours the sacrifice he
made for the rest of the town when he confronted
the group of soldiers about to attack them.
Abuela wells up with emotion at the
memory of Pedro and remains at the
mural overnight until the following day
a child tells her where Mirabel is.
And in the alternate ending, Abuela also confesses
how after Pedro's death she held on too tight to
her family, afraid to lose them again.
After I lost him, I was so afraid.
I couldn't bear the thought
of losing anyone else.
And I realise now that my husband would be...
so disappointed, because of
all the people he would have wished
to understand his words, it was me.
And I am so sorry.
A touch of this did make it into the final film:
I was given a miracle.
A second chance.
And I was so afraid to lose it that I
lost sight of who our miracle was for.
And I am so sorry.
There's also a fascinating alternate
reconciliation between Mirabel and Abuela
hinted at in this concept art where Alma's hair
transformed into a river that ran for miles and
Mirabel had to find and follow the path of the
river in order to reach her grandmother.
The idea here was to explore Abuela's PTSD
following her husband's death, and I think
the fantastically long river would have
been a metaphor for the depth of Alma's sorrow
and how hard it was to reach her emotionally.
The concept of Abuela's hair as a river also fits
nicely with Colombia's famous magical realism
which also inspired the rest of movie, including
the yellow butterflies and magical rooms.
Now, if you'd love to see even more
deleted capybara moments including
them trash-talking the Madrigals, be sure
to subscribe and hit the notification bell
to get my next video where I'll be talking
about that and more Encanto deleted scenes.
I'll add a link here and in the
description as soon as it's ready.
So, what do you think of these alternate endings?
And what would like to see happen in
a future Encanto sequel or series?
Let me know in the comments below.
Next, tap left to discover everything you missed
in Encanto and if you enjoyed this video, then
do leave a thumbs-up, I really appreciate it.
Thanks for enjoying this movie with me and hope
you have a marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!